[Applause]
[Music]
now I don't know what that stuff was but
I don't think it was pumpkin juice
anyways continuing on with the revisit
of the films in the Harry Potter
franchise we have arrived at the fourth
entry Harry Potter and the Goblet of
Fire
so I was really kind of wondering what I
would think of this because and maybe
I'm putting too much weight in the
people who did say this and I'm having a
disproportionate sense of how many
people said it but it seemed like a fair
number of the comments in the video I
did on Prisoner of Azkaban seem to be
pointing towards people not really
liking Goblet of Fire very much which
was weird because to my memory this is
one of the ones I really liked a lot and
I went in re watching it not having done
so from front to back for a while
wondering you know am I gonna find all
these flaws that didn't see before am I
gonna you know come away feeling
different and no I really like this one
if I were to venture a guess the I think
the book purists get really annoyed with
this one because there is a lot of cut
material and especially with Goblet fire
which is a thick book with a lot going
on and a lot that unfortunately adds a
lot of stuff that adds a great deal of
flavor but doesn't actually contribute
to the primary plot which means a lot
that gets cut and even despite that we
have a two and a half hour move to an
our plus movie so I you know I I'm sure
I'll see in the comments people laying
out more specific stuff and I know this
is kind of Oslo point where a lot of
people start a lot of people really like
Ron from the books get really annoyed
with the portrayal of Ron from the
movies I'm not gonna delve into that too
much here because I haven't reread the
books recently enough to really break
something like that down
there was a really great video on it
that another channel did not too long
though so check that out if you don't
know what's going on there that I found
that very enlightening but anyways
Goblet of Fire had a lot that it had to
either trim shorten or just cut entire
subplots the entire premise of spew the
house elves at all like Dobby and I mean
the character of Winkie never appears in
the films at all but Dobby is a major
factor in this plot in the book he's not
in this movie there's a lot more that
goes on at the Quidditch World Cup which
gets massively condensed down the
Dursleys don't appear at all there are
massive things that happen basically
between the trials that get chucked out
because for this thing to make its run
time once its initial permits to set up
that Harry's in this contest it kind of
has to jump from you know trial to trial
to trial and only cover the things that
have to be there for the plot to work so
there's a ton of classroom stuff that
gets cut a lot of the characters who are
wonderful characters don't actually get
a ton to do here but I do actually think
that still makes this for the most part
there are things that I will point out a
really solid adaptation because what it
cuts and trims out is again if you're a
book purist or you like or any of the
stuff they choose to cut with stuff that
you personally liked is going to bother
you but for the sake of the thing
flowing in a film format were the things
that had to be cut I don't love how
little
meantime Snape has in this but Alan
Rickman is so good in the part that I
even though it's one of the only things
he does in the film and it's not even a
line I have always remembered him
standing behind Harry and Ron and just
with his sleeves before he grabs the
back of their heads and just shoves him
forward to look down at their schoolwork
so you know he doesn't have a lot to do
but at this point four films in the
recurring actors know how to get good
mileage out of whatever time they're
given also mention Michael Gambon in
that capacity because I think he's
clicking his Dumbledore much better he
has settled into his version of the role
and the writers yeah I think it's still
still a Steve Clovis for this one seems
to have understood how he is going to
approach it that is different from
Richard Harris so the lions feel more
customed
to his particular take and it's working
better and again like I see people get
really upset at some of his line
readings being different from what is
laid out in the book but I'm sorry
you're gonna give an actor the freedom
to interpret the character and if he
feels reading a line in a way that is
not the way it is described in the book
if it's consistent with the
characterization he's doing that's what
he's going to do and for my part I think
those changes are fine we get a
different director on this one this one
being Mike Newell now this is the only
film in the series he directed I thought
he did a pretty good job he he took on a
lot of the things that Afonso quorum had
brought into it not quite as bright and
colorful a palette as the first two
films although also not quite as subdued
as cuarón had done sort of the more
laid-back naturalistic feel to a lot of
the interactions with the kids is more
prevalent here than it had been
certainly those first two films so
things like that seem to have been taken
from prisoner of azkaban I think that
was really good I'm like I said all the
returning actors are really settling
into their parts the kids are great at
this point they have
terrific chemistry with each other again
some people do take issue with how some
of the characters particularly Iran and
to some extent Hermione are diverging
from their book counterparts but
regardless of what you think about that
the kids have a wonderful report
together
nevel it get some really good highlight
moments we get some more characters
introduced here that I you know we get
to keep seeing again we have the
Pattillo sisters who actually did appear
in the previous film but they they get a
little bit more to do in this one and
we've got the add in characters such as
Fleur Delacour Viktor Krum and of course
Cedric Diggory now floor and crumb they
get a little bit of the short shrift
again because of the runtime that is
available and no you're not really
expected to be rooting for them at any
point so they were always just kind of
the also-rans as far as the competitors
in this contest goes we do need to get
some inveterate and some investment into
Cedric because if we don't then when he
dies spoiler alert then then it doesn't
matter the way that it should and I'll
get to that sort of ending stretch in a
little bit I do want to touch on some of
the things that that that are some of
the stumbling points and I've really
only got two major ones because I mean
if I don't have a time nitpicks on this
again I know there are a lot of people
who do have a lot of nitpicks on this
film and I could acknowledge them and I
have with some of them but I just don't
share a lot of those criticisms but
here's to that I do have the first is
the extensions of Harry's trial get with
the dragon completely unnecessary in the
book that it just happens you know
within the arena it's intense and Harry
does what he needs to and it's done here
the dragon breaks free and they go on
this extended chase over Hogwarts and
the Dragons like smashing up
castle and it's it's unnecessary the
dragon is threatening enough as it is
this doesn't add anything except time
and allowed them to I guess throw more
money at the movie which they didn't
need to do and extending the scene
doesn't add anything is completely
unnecessary and as much as I said they
were pretty smart in what they kept in
what they ditched as far as plot lines
subplots character moments etc there is
one thing that they included that they
included poorly and that's Rita Skeeter
so this is the news reporter with The
Daily Prophet the one who keeps writing
stories that just the other characters
don't like she seems to know stuff that
they that they're trying to figure out
how to achieve and find out about that
except you know that element of it isn't
in the film which is kind of where I'm
going with this they drop the payoff for
the entire Rita Skeeter plotline because
everything culminates in the final
payoff for her in the book which is that
they find out she's an animagus who can
turn I think it's a bug and she's been
she's been bugging them she's been
spying on them in this tiny form that
they can't see to get a lot of the
information that she puts into her
articles they find that out and they and
they basically blackmail her for
information threatening to reveal that
she can do that she does this and you
know has been illicitly obtaining
information for use for probably every
story she's ever written and that that
final payoff is why she's there but
because the movie doesn't have that Rita
Skeeter doesn't actually serve a
function in the film there's no point to
her being there she's just annoying and
I'm sorry she's she is in fact annoying
and with the character that irritating
who I I at least don't find very
inherently fun if you're gonna cut the
payoff then you should cut the character
if you're gonna keep the character he
needs to keep the payoff they kept the
character cut the payoff no
that doesn't work so new characters I
mentioned Cedric you know and and I'm
sure some people will go uh Twilight boy
like look get over it he's he's really
good in this he's he at the time he
appear on this he's young he's handsome
he's charismatic he's very likable which
is exactly what Cedric needed to be and
then we've also got mad-eye moody being
played wonderfully over-the-top very
very fun to watch we get David Tennant
thanks to our twist ending at the end
and we we get the guy playing his dad
who was a villain and Doctor Who and
a-tearin terror era story that I always
find that fun and amusing that that one
oh one other nitpick this one I do [ __ ]
I the the look on the Death Eaters isn't
good giving them like the sharp-pointed
hoods that's I'd like I know the KKK is
a us thing so I maybe they didn't think
that that was how it looked but I'm also
inclined to think that they knowing what
the Death Eaters are meant to evoke as a
group I'm more inclined to think they
did that deliberately to take some kind
of hate group iconography and it's just
it's too on the nose and it's not
necessary and it looks dumb and I'm
really glad they ditched the pointed
hats when they brought back Death Eaters
in later films another thing that they
did that was a very very good move is
they severely condensed down the scene
in the graveyard particularly Voldemort
because I remember reading the book when
he first reformed his body I remember
thinking oh my god but then he just kept
talking and talking and talking and I
remember reading that I remember
flipping how many more pages are in this
chapter is he ever gonna shut up and he
still monologues
but at least he doesn't monologue for
freaking ever like he does in the book
and there's a lot of moments in this
that are really just well delivered well
executed like I said the the actors
really all know their parts very well by
now the chemistry between the returning
actors is great but and there's a reason
that this movie turned up when I did my
list of movies that always make me cry
because Cedric's death not the death
itself necessarily because it's very
quick and it then leaps right into
Voldemort so you kind of don't
necessarily have time to fully process
it when it happens but then they get
back and Cedric is on the ground and
Harry is breaking down and then Cedric's
dad comes down and loses it and that
gets me every single time and maybe I
give the film overall more credit than
it deserves because of moments like that
that hit me so hard like hit me harder
than the book did the deficit Rick was
Cedric was just the thing that happened
in the book the movie actually made it
hurt
at least at least for me so I know that
a lot of fans especially the book
purists don't like this one because of
how much material was cut but look it's
a two-and-a-half-hour movie there's only
a few bits of fat on it that don't need
to be there basically Rita Skeeter and
the length of the Dragon chase
everything else that's here is what's
need to be here and there wasn't room
for anything else and that's just the
nature of a movie and if you still
prefer the book that's fine but you
have to adapt to the medium you're using
if this had been adapted as a TV show
you could do an entire season of
television off of the fourth book
especially you could easily get 10
episode 10 hour-long episodes out of
this thing and incorporate everything
that's not what they did they made a
movie and I for one think they made a
really good movie Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire I think it's really good
I think it's one of the better ones
oh I mean certainly so far in my rewatch
to my memory when I've thought about
ranking before it's been towards the top
again we'll see if how things recess but
of these first four this is my favorite
of the first floor just is not gonna
apologize I think it's very good Harry
Potter and the Goblet of Fire you've
seen it lately what do you think about
it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's stuff that you can
do because you can leave comments which
is awesome
you can like which helps me out you can
subscribe to catch more stuff that I do
in the future you can hop onto patreon
and maybe even help me out a little bit
help me cover my bills maybe make the
channel and the things I do on it even
better there's other links of things
besides that so much stuff down there go
click on it or don't you don't have to
at the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time
Accio wine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]